Сегодня я с вами хотел бы поговорить о
том как не обижаться и не
Разочаровываться в людях Почему важно
досмотреть это видео до конца потому что
обиды и разочарования - это Разрушители
нашей жизни это Разрушители наших
отношений с другими людьми а разрушенные
отношения с другими людьми влияют
напрямую на качество нашей жизни а также
на нашу способность достигать наших
целей Поэтому если вы хотите быть
успешным и достигать многого в этой
жизни а самое главное быть
счастливым досмотрите это видео до конца
Давайте по порядку разбирать эти две
вещи обида и разочарование что же такое
обида обида - Это неоправданное ожидание
Это неоправданное ожидание Когда вы
ожидаете от людей либо от событий
а тех последствий которые по факту не
случились если привести простой пример
это очень часто в быту в жизни случается
например предположим у вас День рождения
вы ожидаете что какой-то человек вам
подарит хороший подарок а он подарок не
подарил или вообще не поздравил Что
произошло вы ожидали одно получилось
другое Или например вы идёте с работы
уставший холодный голодный и ожидайте
что на пороге вас встретит радостная
довольная жена благодарная она для вас
что-то приготовила горячее вкусненькое А
вы приходите а жена вам говорит Ну вот
опять ты пропал пропадал на работе Ты
про семью забыл про детей забыл Где ты
ходишь что происходит происходит с вашей
стороны обида потому что вы ожидали одно
а получили совсем другое обида - это
своего рода небольшой кризис в
отношениях и этот кризис прежде всего
формируется за счёт из-за того что ваша
картинка ожидания не соответствует той
картинки реальности которая по факту
случилась Что нужно чтобы не обижаться
на людей первое делай это не для людей
делай это для Всевышнего тогда вам не
придётся обижаться на людей Э что они
вас не отблагодарили что они что-то не
сделали и так далее Всё что вы делаете
ждите благодарности от Всевышнего не
ждите Это от людей поэтому Когда вы для
кого-то что-то делаете или когда вы
условно поздравляйте с днём рождения не
ждите в ответ что он поздравит не ждите
в ответ что Он подарит вам такой же
подарок Когда вы работаете для того
чтобы обеспечить свою семью делайте это
не ради жены и ради детей делайте это
ради Всевышнего тогда вы не будете
обижаться и это очень важное правило
Давайте теперь рассмотрим что же такое
разочарование разочарование - это
неоправданные надежды разница между
обидой и разочарованием заключается в
том что если обида - это неоправданные
ожидания то разочарование - это
неоправданные надежды это это значит вы
неправильно представляли а имели
представление о тех качествах и
свойствах которые вы которыми вы
наделили человек или объект если в
обидах вы ожидали от человека
а какого-то действия да то в
разочаровании вы изначально
неправильными свойствами его наделили и
ожидали а возлагали надежды что он
добьётся каких-то таких результатов и у
вас потом появляется разочарование в
человеке Ну например в отношении А своих
детей у всех родителей есть определённые
э надежды родители э всё все свои усилия
направляют на то чтобы их надежды
оправдались и таким образом зачастую это
доходит до такого маразма что родители
не ребёнка видят а на самом деле в
ребёнке видят те надежды которые
реализуются через ребёнка простой пример
приведу У меня мама всегда хотела чтобы
я стал прокурором района и она возлагала
Большие Надежды она хотела быть мамой
прокурора района А я в своё время хотел
поступить на сельхоз институт на
профессию Игоря И вот вся моя семья они
меня прям сильно убеждали и в конце
переубеди и мне пришлось поступить на
юридический факультет нашего казахского
университета Ну о чём я честно говоря не
жалею Но это как раз тот пример когда
Родите возлагают надежду на своего
ребнка И на самом
деле в ребёнке видит свои надежды нежели
человека но в моём случае Мама нас очень
сильно любила я говорю про другие случаи
когда вы наделяется своего ребёнка
определёнными качествами и свойствами и
видите в нём реализацию своих надежд то
и если это не происходит вас настигает
разочарование поэтому для того чтобы не
попадать в
разочарование
из любви а не в обмен делайте это из
любви а не из своих желаний Чем
отличается делание из любви Когда вы
делаете что-то из любви вы это делаете
бескорыстно и безвозмездно То есть вы
просто любите ребёнка независимо от его
достижений очень часто к сожалению
родители ребнка любят больше если он
достигает
большего
если он достигает меньшего это особенно
хорошо заметно на его оценках в школе
если у него слабо успеваемость такого
ребёнка родители часто ругают и не
поощряют если у него хорошая
успеваемость тогда такого ребёнка
родители начинают баловать
конечно поощрять
достижение это хорошо но это не должно
отражаться на любви к
ребнку свого Реж лють от его оценок ещ
одно большое отличие между обидами и
разочарования заключается в том что
обижаться Вы можете только на людей а
Разочаровываться Вы можете как в людях
так и в объектах Ну например Вы купили
какую-то машину которая может
разгоняться там до 100 км за 3 секунды А
по факту она разгоняется за 5 секунд или
там вы купили машину которая заявлено
что будет расходовать 5 л на 100 км на
самом деле
на 100 м или вы хотели долго мечтали и
купили там Lamborghini или какую-нибудь
машину она ломается постоянно что вас
настигает вас настигает разочарование
потому что вы наделили тот идеальный
образ теми свойствами и качествами
которые в жизни он не подтверждает очень
часто мы
думаем что Нужно прощать людей и мы
прощаем этих людей а потом выя
когда человек опять поступил что-то
неправильно выбрасываете или мы
набрасывается о том показывает то что мы
на самом деле человека не простили
Поэтому я считаю что глубокое прощение
возможно только тогда когда вы меняете
отношение к поступкам и отношения к
другим людям здесь это очень важно когда
вы меняете отношения
ва не фундамента и почвы для обид
соответственно вам нету смысла кого-то
прощать А если у вас остался фундамент и
почва для обид то как бы вы не прощали
Вы на самом деле просто это обиду свою
заткнули в шкаф подальше но она
однозначно вылезет и однозначно
выстрелит в эмоциональном состоянии
поэтому не тете себя иллюзиями что вы
можете кого-то простить и
забыть Измените сво отношение на то о
котором я сегодня вам говорил приведу
вам сразу два правила чтобы не обижаться
и не Разочаровываться в людях резюмируя
сегодняшнее видео первое что бы ты не
делал для людей делай это для Всевышнего
ради Всевышнего а не ради людей Людям
свойственно быть неблагодарным Людям
свойственно забывать те хорошие вещи
которые вы для него сделали люди бывают
невнимательные
поэто их человек целый день занят
решением собственных проблем и очень
часто он просто забывает Про твоё
отношение или про твои проблемы поэтому
если он не ответил взаимностью не надо
сразу обижаться Поэтому если что-то вы
сделали для
человека Единственный способ это сразу
забыть это делать Это для Всевышнего
Когда вы делаете для человека делайте
это ради Всевышнего и вы знаете что
Всевышний всё помнит он вс видит и он
вас отблагодарит а от человека ожидать
ничего не стоит и тогда что получится те
люди которые вас отблагодарят и те люди
которые вам сделают какое-то благо в
обмен на ваше для вас это будет очень
приятным сюрпризом и бонусом в этой
жизни вы будете просто Кайфовать от
таких действий людей и самое интересное
когда вы будете радостно воспринимать их
благодарность и радостно кайфовать и
радоваться их действиям которые сделали
для вас что-то таким образом вы просто
те этих людей делать для вас ещ больше
добра вы как бы
подсвечивает вас им становится Приятно
просто вам оказывать какую-то услугу или
делать для вас что-то второе что бы вы
не делали для людей для родных делайте
это из любви а не в обмен на что-то и
чтобы не Разочаровываться делайте всё из
любви Всё бескорыстно просто для себя
Определите Вы любите это или не любите
Если не любите от этого надо избавляться
а то что вы любите делайте это
бескорыстно и
не пытайтесь видеть в этом свою Надежду
то есть не лелей свою надежду лелей
любовь к этому человеку вот два основных
лайфхака чтобы не обижаться и не
Разочаровываться